all right so you've you've been around
Japan for like a few days now few days
you said you've tried the different
sandwiches that Hassan's bought have you
tried a lot more combini food as well
um so we were talking about this last
night yeah
you told us that the one we liked the
most was the worst okay what do you
think is the best food you want to say
it um I want you to say it like it like
just in like the type of food or like
sure sure in terms of like I like these
sandwiches a lot okay especially because
you can just save them oh yeah yeah you
can throw them in the fridge and they're
still good yeah and they're so
inexpensive everything here is crazily
inexpensive I feel like I think most of
the sandwiches including conversion is
like two dollars or something yeah which
is uh less than like yeah like it's you
can't get anything for that's not not
even a McChicken and McChickens aren't
that good I'm never getting sponsored by
it cut that out
they're pretty good but they're like
where I live it's like still like three
dollars or so a few years have you
always been on like West Coast America
like I pretty much lived in California
like my whole life so yeah so you've
been used to high prices your entire
yeah yeah you don't miss the crust of
your sandwiches
Connor doesn't like the bread
I remember you mentioned it wasn't like
oh Japanese bread sucks compared to like
European bread it's so bad but then
below Japanese bread is American bread
which is like the worst what exactly is
American bread yo Wonder Bread is
awesome is that what Americans yeah
that's American I've actually never had
that before so what
how have I had it does anyone go to the
store and buy Wonder Bread does that
well I mean the fact that they're still
selling it I assume so yeah but like
it's just a general on the Shelf Brad
that you get in America is pretty bad
yeah like the supermarket kind of bread
yeah I I remember the first time uh you
know I was uh staying in Wisconsin for
like two months or something uh and I
remember buying a loaf of bread there
and in England I'm used to you buy a
loaf of bread and you either finish it
in a week and it feels like that's too
long yeah yeah I was like you either
finish it yeah that's that's like the
max right you have to finish it within a
week or you're gonna get mold in it and
I remember I forgotten I bought this
bread and I've looked at it two weeks
later clean nothing and Sydney was like
oh yeah um that's still like totally
fine don't worry about it totally fine
it's like three weeks to a month or
something and you can still at least
insane meanwhile in Japan it's like you
buy a loaf of bread it's like you know
within the next 20 minutes yeah
it reminds me of a chair we did a
charity stream we were doing a week-long
charity events one of them was where we
could buy a lot of stuff from small
businesses and shout out to small
business if it's good right right
there's one where it was Jam you jam
with bread right right we had bread that
was I think a month past the best by
date and we just ate it anyway
we find true in America right we didn't
get sick so uh
have you seen that video where it's some
guy took uh like took an extended uh
shot of McDonald's and left it out and
then the fries were just like
indestructible oh yeah later yeah they
were just immune yeah they just like a
year later they looked exactly the same
and I'm like I I I had a feeling
something like this would happen but
seeing it just right in front of my face
yeah it's probably because of all the
oil they used they just like mummified
the fries there's got to be some more
than oil honestly yeah a little more
than oil sure definitely oil alone can't
do that yeah it's immortality yeah
otherwise we just like soak ourselves in
McDonald's oil and just find the secret
to immortality yeah
no McDonald's oil the ancient Egyptians
could have learned tunnels or something
yeah it's just like you know like you
know there's people in Japan that just
lived like 110 or something yeah like
what's your secret and it's like I stay
up late to get the oil from McDonald's I
hate McDonald's every day of my life
that's my secret Jesus yeah what's like
your so since this is your first time
out of the US what's been your first
experiences of just like another culture
um it's cleaner and safer is the
craziest thing yeah like there's like
they just leave their bikes around yeah
three bikes it's crazy because in LA
right if you leave your bike even if you
lock it like you can lock your bike to a
post right and if it's not a good enough
lock or even if it is and it's a nice
bike it'll be gone in like five minutes
usually London's kind of the same yeah
uh I know that you always walk past
bikes where the train is still on but
both wheels are gone yeah all that
happens often yeah and it's like God
damn I think though in the case of Japan
the reason why I mean it's mostly also
just the fact that people just aren't
willing to steal [__] for in general but
I think in case with bikes the reason
why people aren't just going around
breaking logs is because like most
people have their own bikes and also a
lot of the bikes are very inexpensive to
sell it I think in the states all right
yeah they still if you see a thousand
dollar bike just sitting there that's a
three thousand dollars okay never mind
but also in Japan like a lot of them
even locked yeah a lot of the bikes are
like a hundred dollars yeah very cheap
bikes and it's like is it really worth
potentially going to prison for stealing
a tire from a 100 bike yeah uh I think I
mean I I have an expensive bike and I've
I've left it unlocked well the places
actually try and Hunt someone down here
like oh like in the States you can get
robbed call the police and they'll be
like we'll think about helping you at
some point I
really valuable right yeah yeah even if
it's really valuable I'm not so I don't
know if we should talk some of our
friends Cars got stolen oh yeah well I
sold the lottery
I don't think the police did much yeah
loving on this video said that he called
the police and they were like oh no that
department isn't working today yeah yeah
you can literally I think Miss cars uh
he has a pretty expensive car I don't
know the exact price yeah right they
just don't care they'll be like oh your
car's stolen
um we'll think about it and they'll just
hang up or something um well then you
have to track it himself or something
because I saw you yeah if anyone has
seen this car yeah please like you know
please let us know don't let the police
know just let us know so what had
happened from what I heard was he
actually found the car himself yeah and
instead of just trying to steal it back
he was like I'm gonna call the police
and they'll handle it yeah um so he
called the police and was like hey my
car's stolen I guess I found it uh can
you help me get it back yeah they just
never showed up I guess and he just took
it back himself is the story I heard oh
my God so I was like yeah I feel like I
don't know if you told me they would try
and catch a guy for stealing a bike
you're like nah there's no way right but
like but like if you think about it is
it considered stealing if you're just
taking back something that someone stole
from you oh no I meant like the the oh
the guy who's got all the guys I guess
it's also dangerous as well yeah in the
US well I'm not I want to steal a car
who knows what other crimes uh yeah I
don't know in Japan a lot of they don't
have guns here there's no guns yeah well
that you you can get guns but you have
to it's well it's like hunting guns and
you've gone through an extremely long
process and it's like you've got to get
a license for uh it takes a while but I
mean like uh yeah I mean the police in
Japan don't have a lot going on and they
have a lot of police yeah long you can
feel like how much they need to do yeah
because the government likes giving jobs
to people and so they're just like you
just become a policeman so they have
like tears of policemen on like how
useful they are yeah
um that whole thing though about like
the department being unavailable is
that's why yeah that's crazy could you
imagine if you like broke your arm and
you like hold up a hospital and be like
oh sorry the doctor's just not entered
this is really police right I think
because the police are like ah it's not
I know like during the pandemic they
were like if it's if the items stolen is
below this amount the police won't show
up yeah if it was under a thousand
dollars the police won't show off that's
crazy because it's not worth the time to
send the police it's like the opposite
in Japan where police look for any
excuse to do something even if it's like
the most minor dis uh misdemeanor or
something like that they're all like the
entire Army will show well even if they
spawn they spawn like like in cyberpunk
oh my God like if you're doing sex
attack or something yeah yeah like if
you if you're like you're having a bad
interaction with a cop within five
minutes there'll be 20 more yeah okay
it's like you know you're a trip over
the wrong guy and then you immediately
immediately get five stars in GTA yeah
that's kind of how it is yeah I remember
once I'm kind of like pressed the wrong
button on his intercom which we like he
didn't know at the time like was a
security button that you press in case
someone something happened I was worried
you pressed it when you guys are messing
with the AC your Airbnb oh wait yeah
there was there was a button where I was
like I was trying to turn the lights on
and off and like there are all the all
the buttons are labeled some of them
actually have English a lot of them just
have like you know the letter or I don't
know what it's called like it can't as a
country yeah yeah and I was like I don't
know what this means trying to figure
out which one turns on which light and
I'm like oh this one doesn't do anything
I pushed it a few times and I'm like
maybe I should stop pushing it
no police showed up you still don't know
what the button does but it did
something yeah I remember we were around
Connor's place the other day
um and I think uh uh he had a few people
over and uh Rob CD was there yeah and
kind of and someone called the intercom
and uh Connor was like oh can someone
like get that please Rob Rob presses a
button and I'll and he was like I don't
know what button and I just pressed he
takes his finger off and we realize it's
the security button yeah and we were
like oh Connor get here now otherwise 10
policemen are about to come here and
then they're just they'll think you're
breaking in they'll be like yeah exactly
well yeah they call you back and they're
like was that an accident and you're
like yes they're like okay yeah say it
as panicked as possible here like yes
yes most Apartments have this and you
pay monthly for it I you don't even get
a choice like I can't be like no I don't
want it like they they force you to pay
for it right and yeah but essentially
it's like a private Army that will show
up yes yeah the second one I think it's
cool yeah yeah they're like the it's
like one company that runs it all in
Japan oh is it a private company it's
private yeah yeah that's interesting
that's interesting um yeah that's scary
I actually I pressed it also my like
first few weeks in Japan I pressed it at
someone else's house and uh I'm like now
I'm just gonna be afraid to push any
button okay okay go to everyone's house
I'll be like could you turn the lights
on okay so so here's the trick uh it'll
be red no other button should be read
and if it is that absolutely trolling
you and it's not your fault oh like the
huge button itself no no the kanji will
be red everything else should be black
or another color but the kanji one will
be red yeah um and it's normally like a
it's it should be pretty small but for
some reason in this apartment it was
huge and it was it was and it was dead
center and so the thing started ringing
and they weren't there and I pressed it
uh and then I think they called them but
they missed it and I was just waiting
for them to come back and I'm just
chilling in the living room that's scary
and then uh I start seeing like flashing
lights outside I thought oh well you
know someone some idiot it's got a place
called on yeah yeah
and then my friend came back and and
they got a phone call and they were like
why do I have eight missed calls I was
like I don't know I was watching like
Japanese MasterChef
yeah I'm playing TFT and then uh they
get another call and they start freaking
out and I'm like wow that's wrong and
they look out the window they're like oh
my God I'm like what they're like eight
police cars they're like yeah all these
police cars are here for us and I was
like what oh God because none of the
calls were picked up they're like this
guy's being yeah yeah because no one had
picked up the calls
um so if you do press it not the end of
the world just make sure whoever's there
answers the thing yeah and explains and
then like a whole dude it was like a it
was like a comedy skit slowly they they
knock on the door and open it up and
slowly opening up this door and this
tiny Japanese like apartment foyer area
where like because you know like the
room between Apartments is Tiny yeah you
open it up and there's like eight dudes
in full like SWAT armor oh God we're
just there and then there's just like
like him like a like a movie there's
this tiny dude comes around the corner
like four foot whips out a notebook and
is like well well well oh God what we
got here then huh died June I see
Foreigner huh don't need his details
yeah grilled me took all my information
asked me about my all my employment and
everything for like an hour and then
they finally left me alone even though
my friend was like no I just dude just
chill and I was like
that does not sound yeah that's where I
learned the kanji for uh I don't know
what it means but I know not to press
that can't you yeah it's so impressed
what's the kanji really say I don't know
it depends it's the same kanji
everywhere maybe which is like emergency
yeah it might be kinky I know what it
looks like if you told me I'm like don't
press that yeah I just won't turn any
lights on in anyone's house
usually the light switches are like one
yeah
don't don't touch the Instagram yeah I
won't touch anything like I'll be like
is this the one could you turn the light
on please you need to go to the I think
when I first walked in I didn't turn the
light on that was on purpose right I'm
just kidding I couldn't find the lights
outside I'm used to the light switch
being in the in the bathroom
what if I'm in the bathroom out there
and and you're just like I'm gonna play
a prank on this guy and you just turn
the lights off oh Hotel rules it's fine
I can't see anything